when humans leave the earth for good
they're gonna need a comfy place to stay
International Space Station has just the
place it's something like a big bouncy
castle for kids just built to house
astronauts solar system colonists and
tourists looking for an
out-of-this-world vacation
the prototype bouncy castle is on its
way to space this week it's called the
Bigelow expandable Activity module or
beam and it will stay attached to the
ISS for two years a few weeks after it
arrives astronauts will press a button
and the module would begin its automated
inflation process growing from the space
station side like a zit the size of a
small bedroom imagine it a small bounce
house bedroom in space although
tragically it will remain empty for most
of the time except four times a year the
station's astronauts will get to
actually you know inhabit the place for
three hours at a time they'll collect
data about the modules temperature
pressure and radiation hopefully those
check-ins will show that the technology
is safe enough to actually live in if it
all works out Bigelow plans to install
blowup houses around the solar system
and perhaps beyond maybe this is the
start of the first hotel chain in space
you